they can say that all white people are
complicit in whiteness by virtue of the
color of their skin and they can also
say that people who are non-white are
also complicit in the system if they are
not actively anti-racist remember for
these people
isn't the dichotomy of racist or not
racist because if you're not racist
that's another form of racism the
dichotomy is actually racist or
anti-racist which means you are
proactively conceding your own
complicity in these systems
and and attempting to decolonize these
systems right so it's not good enough
just not to be a racist person to be a
good person who doesn't ever
say or do or support anything racist
that's not enough you've got to be an
anti-racist
andrew welcome to the show lovely to be
back
it's been a while how long's it been
more than a year just over a year you
were
on route from london to the fringe
dropped in for a quick coffee in there
that's right
that's right yeah it was fun but none of
that none of that anymore that's not how
the world works now
no it's all remote it is you're you're
on uh
on holiday at the moment somewhere nice
i'm not
really i'm working i'm on the amalfi
coast uh i'm staying in a small town
uh halfway between positano and amalfi
and i'm i spent the day in capri the
other day so it's
not been to pompei so it sounds like i'm
having a good time but i am here to work
and so for the rest of the week i'm not
going to leave the flat i'm just going
to sit here and write because i can't
work
at home too many distractions you're
really my normal future
way too um no i'm not i'm i'm working on
a new book
and because the last two books i wrote i
wrote in sarc the isle of sark but i
can't get there
because of the quarantine rules so i had
to come to italy
so uh you know it's fine yeah it's a
tough life isn't it yeah
yeah if it's good it's good i mean i've
got the space i need just to focus on
stuff
i like it so what have been the major
developments in the
wok world this year i mean where'd you
begin
uh it it has exploded when i last spoke
to you
uh i was often accused of exaggerating
the problem
and people would say well you know
you're just complaining about the
behavior of a few rogue students here
and there on university campuses or
a few nut cases on the internet um and
well i've been proven right haven't i
because now it's not that it's
demonstrably not that the evidence of
everything i've been writing about and
talking about
for the past five years is absolutely
everywhere it's incontrovertible and if
that sounds arrogant so be it
but there you go the prophet has arrived
i [ __ ] told you
you just attacked me i am cassandra you
didn't believe my
warnings and here we are you know had
you heeded
my prophecies perhaps this could have
been evaded so other than you being one
of the
one of the four horsemen where where is
the world of
if if there's trends if there was like a
trending in the world of walk so
where's it gone this year yeah so it's
been a kind of just a concatenation of
unfortunate circumstances you know we
had the
uh obviously the pandemic and the
lockdown and this created this kind of
tension and this kind of um
this sense of frustration it meant a lot
of people were spending more time on the
internet
uh rather than the real world which
means that they have a skewed
perspective of how things are going and
and then all of a sudden it explodes uh
because of the death of george floyd so
there's this
you know what starts out as very
important uh legitimate protests against
police brutality
i'm personally very uh nervous about any
kind of overreach of the state as you
know because you know you know about my
work so
i i do believe instances like that do
require
rigorous response and rigorous protest
um but very
quickly it became quite clear that this
wasn't about george floyd anymore it was
about
this whole host of other issues and it
was actually more a kind of catalyst
for the culture war to explode into the
mainstream which is exactly what
happened and then you have
all major corporations all major
businesses civic institutions
uh schools universities absolutely
everyone in lockstep
over uh basically issues they don't
fully understand you know i mean
when the bbc for instance um and
sainsbury's as of this week
uh telling their employees to read white
fragility by robin d'angelo which is a
book which is uh
i suppose the most popular example of of
critical race theory
that we have at the moment but it is a
very um uh very shoddy
uh piece of work um which has been
widely discredited and and and
doesn't have the kind of academic
respectability once you move beyond that
sort of
niche of the kind of post-modern
offshoots such as
uh you know critical race theory
disability studies fat studies gender
studies intersectional feminism once you
go beyond all that
people don't take robert d'angelo very
seriously businesses do corporations do
they pay her thousands of dollars to go
in and shout at their white employees
and tell them how racist they all are
but
it's such a dangerous divisive backward
philosophy of life it's it's the idea
that you divide us into oppressed and
oppressor
irrespective of our personal
circumstances and you you
you know it's racist in every way it is
possible to be racist it
you know it degrades people of color by
telling them that they're always going
to be victims that they never they will
never
achieve anything that they deserve to
achieve and it's racist against white
people because it tells them that
they're all
oppressive and racist and in particular
robert d'angelo who will claim that if
you deny your complicity in white
supremacy that just proves your white
supremacist right so this
it's it's absolutely appalling and
abysmal and of course
because she used the phrase and well
people of that ilk use the phrase
anti-racism to describe what they're
doing
if you complain about anti-racism will
make the case that anti-racism is a bad
thing it sounds like you're saying that
you are
for racism and of course the reason for
opposing anti-racism
is if you are concerned about actual
racism that's the problem so
this gets very complicated there's this
whole lexicon you sort of have to
you have to master before you can get
anywhere it also makes people
rightly nervous they understand that you
know most people
are are concerned about uh the
anti-racism in terms of
unconscious bias training implicit bias
training dividing people up i mean
sainsbury's literally created an online
safe space for their black employees i
mean how patronizing is that
so people are nervous about this but
they don't want to be seen to be opposed
to anti-racism it's a very clever
phrase that they use but what people
have to understand is that anti-racism
is a rehabilitated form of racialized
thinking in other words it is a form of
racism
and if you really care about combating
racism as i do
then you will oppose anti-racism and
you'll go back to
the liberal approach uh the liberal
approach to combating racism
and the reason why that's a good thing
is we've got the past six decades
of progress which prove that it works
and sure
it hasn't achieved a complete utopia
where racism doesn't exist
that will never happen because we live
in a society of human beings
and there's always going to be some
nasty pieces of work amongst us right
but the best the absolute best way as
has been proven by recent history
is the liberal approach is that you
would tackle racism rigorously whenever
it occurs
what you don't do is create this
faith-based philosophy where there are
nebulous power structures
that only people like robin d'angelo are
qualified to detect
and therefore you implement policy on
that basis in the government in the arts
in education in the media
absolutely everywhere and then you're
solving problems that may or may not
exist on the basis of this
this deity that you've created that's
not the way to go about this
and we know this is the case so people
who do believe in those liberal values
those decent values of equality and
fairness and
and looking out for people and ensuring
that people aren't mistreated in society
and discriminated against
those are the people who need to advance
the liberal
uh agenda the social liberalism that has
served us so well
for so long uh that is now being utterly
demolished before our eyes
it seems or it feels a little bit like
you know the god of the gaps
theory this is kind of like the racism
of the gaps theory yes racism is the set
point and that is the elephant in the
room with regards to the anti-racism
movement
that it inherently further entrenches
and splits us up
into groups based on race as opposed to
the sam harris proposal which is a world
where the colour of someone's skin would
be as important as the colour of
someone's hair
and we don't care that there's not
enough
the ceos or brunettes that are working
on the the machine line or whatever it
might be um
one thing i've noticed this year race
really has sort of come to the forefront
what's happened with the gays this year
is gay activism still alive and well
i think the gays are a new white man
aren't they i think that
people are quite down on the gays at the
moment and there's all sorts of things
that you've just kind of touched on
which are quite difficult to unpack i
mean
you you were alluding to the the ideal
of color blindness which is of course
the ideal
the liberal ideal which is that as you
say the ginger hair analogy works well
because we
it doesn't mean that you don't see race
it means that you don't
uh care you don't care you don't you
don't treat
people differently on it on on on the
basis of skin color which is actually a
beautiful
uh ideal that we should all be striking
that's how that's what we use to teach
children and all of a sudden
over the past six months suddenly all of
that needs to be unpicked and unpacked
and re
and and and revised based on this very
reactionary agenda i think that's
absolutely uh heartbreaking and
genuinely uh tragic
and yes reactionary and regressive
regressive it's taking us right back
um and that's the thing you don't need
you know we've can anyone seriously hand
on heart say
that what has happened this year has not
inflamed racial tension and made it
worse and it
and basically made our society more
racist as opposed to less racist i mean
can anyone seriously say that
with a straight face uh i don't believe
they can um so
that's why we do need to do something
about it in terms of gays
where are the gays andrew where are all
of the gays gone
so the the that's a different issue the
problem with the gay
issue now is that we have uh there is a
kind of
fission within the lgbtqia plus
community right so
what even using the phrase makes me
laugh i think we need to totally just
abolish it and move on because
the truth is uh let's take stonewall
stonewall which is the
sort of major charity for gay people in
the uk which has done some incredible
work over the years and has now
changed its entire philosophy about
sexuality and
it and and it believes for instance that
gay men
are it's redefining not homosexuality is
no longer same sex attraction it is same
gender attraction but of course gay men
are not attracted
to uh people who identify as men
they are attracted to people who have
the bodies of men right and that's
actually quite a fundamental distinction
a lesbian
is not going to uh be attracted to
someone with a penis simply because that
person with a penis identifies as female
and because that person says that well
it's a female penis that's not because
we're dealing with people's
biological uh inclinations sexual
inclinations it's quite deeply rooted
shall we say um so when
stonewall effectively adopt a homophobic
policy right and i use that word uh with
caution in so far as i don't think the
people at stonewall are homophobic but i
think their
new philosophy is underpinned by
homophobia in much the same way that i
don't think fourth wave
feminists are misogynists but their
philosophy is underpinned by
a misogynistic idea that women are weak
inherently weak and always victims and
need protection right so
it's perfectly possible uh to to for
this to happen as we have seen so
stonewall now
uh are obsessed with the the trans issue
i mean their right
to be uh concerned whenever a trans
person is discriminated against
right that is something again we go back
to the liberal standard which is that
uh everyone should have equal rights
irrespective of who they are
or how they identify the liberal
perspective is that you should be able
to call yourself whatever you want you
should be able to
do whatever you want to your body uh you
should you should have those
and of course um trans people have every
right to be treated exactly the same as
everyone else
what they don't have the right to do is
to force other people to use the
language that they want them to use and
that's really the sticking point
um and there is this of course a
conflict of rights now between feminists
who for the most part particularly
second wave feminist and thereafter
believed in
the idea of gender being a social
construct
and of course the trans movement
particularly the militant trans
activists believe that
uh gender is uh by they have a
biological essentialist view which is
why you get this idea being born in the
wrong body
so you get this fundamental
contradiction you also have feminists
who are concerned about single sex
spaces
uh such as domestic violence refuge
centers for instance or prisons
uh which is a legitimate concern to have
uh and they they
do not believe um that biological sex is
is a fantasy
um they you know and and as blair white
as
the trans writer in america has pointed
out if there's no such thing as
biological sex there's no such thing as
trans people
so all of this is going on uh so you've
got
uh lesbians and gay men uh who are being
pitted against trans activists and it's
not really fair
because the majority of trans people
don't have these views this is
this is a minority of activists who for
some reason are able to
sway stonewall's entire policy and
thinking on this
and and stonewall in fact has has
completely stopped listening
to gay people and is completely uh and
feminists and completely overall their
viewpoint
i'm not suggesting that any particular
person uh should just be deemed to be
correct in this i think
we need to have a debate right i'm
perfectly willing to be challenged on
anything that i've said
and for people to say i'm wrong i almost
certainly am wrong about a number of
things that
it's got to be the case right so having
having the discussion is important but
when you have someone just charging in
and saying
trans women are women well there's a lot
to unpack there
you know what do you mean by woman what
does woman mean by your definition what
if i don't share your definition
of woman what if i think that um
sex is a biologically ingrained and that
you are fundamentally incapable of
changing that
however you can identify and you're free
to identify however you want which
by the way is what an awful lot of trans
people believe right according to this
new rubric
a lot of trans people are very
transphobic and that's going to be very
complex
what do you do gay men are not gay men
gay women uh
it's so they're lower down on the
pecking order
yeah so so because of intersectionality
which effectively i know the
original intention wasn't this but what
it has morphed into is a kind of
exactly that yeah a kind of a hierarchy
of grievance and gay people are
dropping down the charts all the time is
there any further for them to go
oh relegated to the vauxhall conference
mate you know
by the way i don't know what that means
really yeah
i just heard a man in a pub say it once
the reason i i
the reason i use that is because when i
was at school uh it was
because i'm i was never a
gender-conforming kid and so i didn't
like the stuff that the boys liked and i
wasn't into
football and everyone was so into
football i had to pretend
that i'd supported a team and i chose a
yoval town
so that i had something to say um and
apparently they got relegated to the
vauxhall conference
and i've always remembered that phrase i
don't even know if the box of confidence
is still a thing i don't think it is but
you've managed to
pull out a like couple of decade old
reference that's still in there it's
still in oh yeah
but it's very traumatic and scary you
know if you're a boy at school at your
primary school and
you're secretly doing ballet in the
evenings and you're you're having
nightmares about them seeing you in your
tights
uh and and and and you're getting
bullied at school and you
and you're not considered very masculine
and traditionally masculine
uh yeah those things stick i think i
think i played cricket
in a state school in
stockton some sub-area of
t-side middlesbrough whose claim to fame
up until recently was
only that it had the highest teen
pregnancy rate in the uk
uh and i i was playing qriket which
which was like just the
the bourgeois arrow over the top of your
head
for uh this guy needs a kicking cricket
cricket is basically pg woodhouse and
that
precisely quintessential old-school
englishness and newtonian kind of yeah
that's
very very very wanky did you see
the campaign to decolonize mars
uh i didn't but well it hasn't been
colonized yet has it
let me let me lay let me lay this one
out for you okay
i haven't come across this one
decolonize mars.org an
unconference on mars decolonizing mars
an unconference on inclusion and equity
in space exploration will bring together
a diverse group of individuals
working at the intersection of
astrobiology anthropology social justice
and space space exploration
the format of the event will feature a
discussion as its primary objective
while there will be time for brief
presentations a significant fraction of
the program will be devoted
to group discussion around pressing
themes which will be determined by the
symposium participants themselves
the term decolonizing decolonization
refers to the undoing of the legacy of
colonialism
many people are used to hearing about
colonizing mars
to talk about humanity living in space
here we examine how using a colonialist
framework in space
reproduces past harm from humanity's
history on earth
this event is about envisioning fresh
pathways for thinking about space
exploration
by stepping away from the ways we
usually talk about space
which is by definition decolonizing the
topic hence decolonizing mars
and as you've quite rightly identified
and james lindsey brought up
there is an entire conference dedicated
to decolonizing a planet that hasn't
been colonized yet
are you sure this isn't a joke
i'm just i'm just putting that out there
it seems well i mean that is that not
the sub title to almost everything
that's happened this year
this is the problem now is that i
whenever i see an article like this or
something i have to verify it do you
wonder sometimes if you wrote it
yeah exactly if you've trolled yourself
yeah
it's i mean it's so on the face of it
just insane
and it's you want to be i mean i i've
always been banging on about
you know how i want to give people the
benefit of the day i want to be
respectful to all opinions and i want to
be able to discuss them but some
the problem with this social justice
ideology is it is at heart
so infantile that it's it's it's it's
it's very difficult
not to start sounding like you're
throwing ad hominems you know what once
you start
but it it just is this isn't how adults
who are educated well should behave
let's not forget as well
we're not talking about you you if you
want to have
the those conferences that happen in
portland where
everyone calls each other comrade and
has a point of personal privilege that's
fine no no no this is [ __ ] space
right there's no that we with the
there's you know it's a vacuum out there
it's really really scary and dangerous
and mars is
far away i don't wha
the astronauts that are going over there
there should not be an inclusivity
officer
on board the first shot
once they've decolonized maths and
science and then and engineering and
then they can build the rocket that goes
to mars i'm not gonna be on
on that rocket i'll tell you because
it's not gonna get very far and
you know if they're obsessed with this
stuff i mean i hope i hope we do meet an
alien race
because because because these people
their first concern is going to be about
whether the alien race is sufficiently
inclusive and diverse
and uh and they'll just shoot them
weren't they with their laser guns and
that'll be the end of that and that'll
be fine
and that's that's what we need we need a
[ __ ] invasion don't we
i i just i don't i don't know what else
to do i am
i'm kind of because i'm writing about at
the moment i'm writing a book about it
as well and i just
it's reminding me of all the stuff
that's going on and i'm trying to i'm
well i have been for the past five years
trying to get into the head
of these people and and there comes a
point when you realize it is just a
fundamentalist religion that's what it
is and therefore
you know it's like trying to pick apart
any kind of rigorous theology
you know you it ultimately you come you
you hit that brick wall
you know where ultimately you just want
to say but actually i don't believe
there is a
a a multi-headed hydra i just don't you
know i so i'm not going to accept the
premise
from which we build your entire esoteric
religion that you know i'm just not
going to do that and that's what we're
dealing with here
and it is a worry and i don't know what
the solution i think we need to
people need to learn things again you
know um
these people have been failed by
education i believe and
i i don't i don't know what to do about
it i i'm concerned
and i brought this up with douglas when
he was on the show
my concern is that the smartest minds of
our generation
are being having their mental ram
taken up trying to argue the fact that
men and women are different
and yeah if the great filter exists
which is
a theory put forward by robin hansen
that explains the
answer to the fermi paradox why are
there no aliens out there there is a
particular barrier that all
uh civilizations need to get over
perhaps it's not
uh do having aggressive global warming
perhaps it's um
having correctly controlled and aligned
artificial general intelligence perhaps
it's
you know any any one of a number of
other things like if
that great filter exists and the reason
that we don't get past it is because
we're playing these
childish like absolutely infantile games
of your hierarchy versus my hierarchy
and i'm going to do moral grandstanding
because it's a state a signaler and blah
blah blah like we don't deserve to
colonize the galaxy
well the problem is though it's it's
such a small i think we do
deserve it it's a small minority of
people who've just taken over academia i
mean that's really all it is and
and people go away to universities and
they are pumped full of this
stuff which is stupid just stupid i mean
the number of the arguments i've seen on
twitter and it's it's blue checked
academics
saying the most ignorant stupid things
and you just think well
those are considered the most educated
people in the world aren't they and that
that's you know
and yet normal people know that they're
full of [ __ ]
and that's a worry that's a worry isn't
it i i don't know
and i don't want to hand conspiratorial
and i know that this idea the long march
through the institutions the gram scout
here is is kind of
considered to be conspiratorial but um
well certainly it wasn't from the from
the outset i mean there were people
there were
neo-marxists who were concerned about
the failure of marxism
uh to to stir up a revolution and they
wanted to know why
and they believed that the way to do it
would be through this kind of inch meal
approach where you do
infiltrate the church say universities
the major institutions
um so there was that blueprint in place
there was an attempt and and and
that's not conspiratorial because they
were so open about those intentions
they wrote about those intentions and um
and it did
happen however i think largely it
happened by accident more than anything
i think it happened by accident i just
think
those sort of uh original thinkers of
the frankfurt school you know the
hawkheimers and the adornos and the and
the and and the and
and the french post models of the 1970s
were coming from a different branch
but they have these sort of overlapping
concerns they just
took hold and i think it happened by
accident more than anything else but it
just
it just took hold and i mean certainly
when i was studying at university
uh that sort of foucaulian idea of the
world you know
uh the power structures that we now hear
about all the time
it was just completely compulsory that
this was just taken as a given
and then it went out of fashion weirdly
um so this obsession that we now have
with language i mean you know that
social justice activist they're all
obsessed with language and
policing language and you mustn't say
this and the reason they think that is
because they think that reality is
created by language effectively if you
can police language
the world becomes better and you and
people think in the right way you know
but all of that stems from this this
post-modern over-emphasis on
on language it's why the post-modernists
had no clue about the visual arts they
were totally ill-equipped
to assess the visual arts right they
couldn't do it because they they just
think linguistically
obsessively the deredars of the world
you know the the the
jean francois leotards of the world is
just obsessing with it with language and
that we now have the legacy of that
um but i should say all of this stuff
went out of fashion about 10 years ago
15 years ago it's just for some reason
uh it's it's it's gone and and and
you've got those sort of
you know the the worst kind of
know-nothing academics who are
holding on to it and the reason they
hold on to it is because if you believe
in this belief system you don't have to
do any reading
you don't have to know anything you
don't have to spend any time in the
library all you do is read a few
a few sort of of these textbooks these
foundational texts and you're good to go
it's why it really it really it makes me
laugh when you hear that phrase educate
yourself and the the activists always
say that
educate yourself but they don't actually
meet first off they haven't read
foucault and derek they haven't read the
things that they cite
when they say educate yourself they mean
read the one or two books they've ever
read
which are probably white fragility by
robin get white fragility on an audible
free trial that's what they mean
yeah or or how to be an how to be
anti-racist by abraham max kennedy
they've basically got those two
maybe the reniedo lodge book maybe an
app
what does the x stand for in ibram candy
is it a name he's changed his name to
that that that's not his birth name
ex candy so that's i i i can only assume
it's
an illusion to malcolm x and to the
practice of of of black activists in the
black power movement changing their name
to
to an ex i okay that's i i don't know
enough about him
me neither oh all i know is i don't like
that book
[Laughter]
and i have to read these books i mean
this is the thing that bothers me i
you know he's just done one called
anti-racist baby i don't know if you saw
that as a
scene it's gone out yeah is it like a
pop-up is it
pop-up but it does people in point no
it doesn't have pop-ups it has it's a
thick it's one of those
um it's aimed at very small kids so it's
one of those
cardboard big big thick so there's only
about seven pages
you can read in two minutes then it's
it's thick illustrated
and he's talking about how babies i'm
not kidding it's something like
babies need to be able to confess their
racism and all this sort you know i mean
it's just hilario it's it is funny it
really is but but
these books i mean i i keep getting them
sent to me as well and i
there comes a point where they're just
curses i mean is there anthrax in them
like
yeah i think i feel like it's a curse um
but of course i also know i have to read
them because i
i can't be in the position of of of
talking about them and criticizing them
unless i'm familiar with them and i'm
you know i read more of that stuff than
the stuff i would like to read or having
said that i'm in italy and i've been
reading
some more interesting there's things
that are not to do with it which is
probably
not what i should be doing you know at
the moment and try to entrench yourself
in yeah
um can you take us through what
whiteness
means okay so
the the notion of whiteness i suppose
the best way to to think about it is a
system of power
right so it's um and this is coming from
critical race
this is the phrase that they always use
whiteness it's been analogized with the
concept with the augustinian idea
of original sin uh it doesn't actually
specifically pertain to well
there's an ambiguity it doesn't
specifically pertain to
the color of your skin the whiteness it
more pertains to a complicity in a
system of whiteness
a system of oppression on the basis of
race right
so for this is why for instance
very confusingly when there was that
story in america when the uh the
the uh the asian boys i think one of
them urinated on a black school girl
and and attacked them it was a kind of a
sort of
it was a horrible attack okay um they
were described because they weren't
white
perpetrators they were described as
enacting whiteness
in other words whiteness is a way that
you oppress
people of color a system of oppression
and that
you don't necessarily therefore have to
be white you could be
you could be white adjacent which is the
phrase that i
i started using last year as a joke
through titania
and now people are using it and i
started thinking did i invent this but i
probably didn't i
it probably was just there in the ether
you know
it's because undiscovered knowledge yeah
i mean you can because you can't
anticipate this stuff you can't
that's that's the problem and and
because fascist adjacent had become so
popular i just thought i'll start
calling
black people who don't have who are
conservatives say white adjacent
as a joke and now i'm actually seeing it
everywhere and it's really bothering me
and i want to work out if i did invent
that
i hope so um but yeah so that's what
whiteness so therefore to give another
example
um and of course there's all sorts of
books and tracks written about
whiteness and and and trying to uh give
it the illusion that this is something
that is thought through
and and and sophisticated is
sophisticated that it's
it's too it you know they load it with
this jargon in order to give the
impression that it's too complicated
for you to understand so you better just
accept hand it over to us
you made you made the analogy that um
the same reason as to why
the church didn't want the bible
translated
into common parlance back in the middle
ages
it's why they burnt tinder at stake
because you translate the bible it means
that they
all of a sudden the power is is is
devolved to the masses it means they can
interpret scripture
for themselves and that matters you know
you don't have you can't just say well
you can't have a priest just say well
you've got to do what i say because i'm
the only one who can read the sacred
texts you know
that is the equivalent of what's
happening here so the academics are
saying well and you see all the time
when people get into
when you your average person gets in an
argument with one of these crazy
academics on twitter
they'll say well actually i'm an expert
in this and they'll throw all this
jargon down
and they'll frighten people away uh and
if you know actually
don't worry about it because they're
talking bollocks they really are
all this comes from is is these these
things are slogans
that that that are used instead of
serious thought processes
and they are they're not to be taken
seriously so don't worry about it just
get them
also you should remind them that if
they're unable to express their point
with any degree of clarity
they're not expressing their point well
that's that's the other thing
it's the mark of a was it it's the mark
of a genius to explain a complex thing
in a simple way is the mark of a
charlatan
to explain a complex a simple thing in a
complex way
very nice did you just come up with that
no i found it on twitter probably but
not in your world so yeah you were
saying another example of whiteness well
just to give another example of the
of the way in which uh the social
justice people and the critical race
people
play on these ambiguities is that they
can say that all white people are
complicit in whiteness by virtue of the
color of their skin and they can also
say that people who are non-white are
also complicit in the system
if they if they are not actively
anti-racist remember for these people
isn't the dichotomy of racist or not
racist
because if you're not racist that's
another form of racism the dichotomy is
actually racist or anti-racist which
means you are proactively
uh conceding your own complicity in
these systems
and and attempting to decolonize these
systems right so it's not good enough
just not to be a racist person to be
good to be a good person who
who doesn't ever say or do or support
anything racist
that's not enough you've got to be an
anti-racist right
so you've got all that going on and then
but then they will play on and make it
racial
so then you've got like the resisting
whiteness uh
conference that was at edinburgh
university where they said explicitly
that in the q and a section at the end
white people were not allowed to put
their hands up and ask
questions so well in that case you are
making whiteness explicitly about skin
color
and in that circumstances what do you do
for your mixed race can you speak in a
low speed how much
how much whiteness are you allowed to
yeah did you get like do you get like
half a question
or or uh you know how do we and also
we're all
mongrels of various races so how much do
you get to speak do i have to have a dna
test to decide how much i can speak so
on the one hand they like the fact that
it alludes specifically to race and skin
color
and on the other hand they will deny
that it does and that race is a social
construct and all the rest of it so
it plays on the ambiguity it plays on it
it's in the same way that
they they play on the idea of of social
justice and liberalism
and they play on people's good natures
and good intentions
in order to get what they want i think
it's absolutely it's absolutely
ghastly so you can have for instance uh
academics who talk about how
uh whiteness is evil and we must abolish
whiteness as we've seen
from a number of i think there was a
cambridge academic who said exactly that
but of course what she's doing is she's
she's enjoying the fact that she can
have a pop of white people
but then she can defend herself by
saying yes but when i say whiteness i'm
talking about this oppressive system
that i've sort that i believe in this
magical system that we all us
fellow academics talk about amongst
ourselves so you can have it both ways
um it's it's really it's really bad it's
like the
the old school um closet racist comedian
that would make
overtly racist jokes and then say just a
joke mate i'm only
i'm i'm not i'm only joking or the same
as the the guy who is
vehemently anti-gay but if you watch
put some gay pawn in front of him and
stick him in front of an mri he's got
much more of an arousal response than
anybody else in the room right
exactly the lady don't protest too much
the oldest trick in the book isn't it
but the bullies always used to say it's
just a joke you know and that's and and
of course real comedians think through
their jokes carefully and decide whether
or not they are justified or not and and
so
yeah that absolutely is it's a it's a
good analogy actually
it's good chris did you see thank you
man i'm just loading the flattery on
today i feel great
um did you see the
the gym i think in portsmouth had done i
did see the gym
the the 12 years of slave uh course
yes because because being a slave was
like a joke
being a slave was hard and so is this
work out
that's a quote yeah i mean being a slave
is hard
um and i'm sure working out as you know
more than most people
is is tough uh it's not the same though
is it
like but i did wonder about that whether
that was some sort of joke uh
turns out it's not no really sadly not
it's just it's just horribly misjudged
well look people are going to make these
uh poor judgments at the moment because
the whole discourse is so crazy
and and i imagine that was actually
quite well intentioned well so
this is this is something else that i
brought up with douglas that i'd had
this conversation with carl benjamin
sargon
and um i got so nervous during the
process
of talking about it was slap bang when
chad was happening so like
peak race tensions yeah yeah and i got
so nervous
not knowing what i was supposed to say
not knowing what wasn't
wasn't acceptable speech and i'm someone
who does this
every single night like four or five
nights a week i have a conversation
about this so
my ability to deploy precise speech
should at least
be better than the lay person and i was
nervous during the day before this
ambient anxiety then after it had
happened i was listening back to it oh
should i have would i have could i have
said that a little bit more of course
and because because we are living in
this in this culture where people will
pick apart
and you can misspeak if you misspeak
even slightly it can be used as
ammunition against you
it's it is what we call council culture
which does exist no matter what oman
jones claims
and the problem is that you you you know
everyone's
worried about what they say now actually
being concerned about what you say and
trying to aim for precise speech is a
good
quality it's something that we should
all do but but we should all there
should also be a recognition that all of
us
will not always express precisely what
we mean
because we're human beings and we make
mistakes and also particularly dealing
with such
sensitive issues and complicated issues
we should have the freedom to make
mistakes i think it's very liberating
to just not care to just think i am
going to make mistakes sometimes and
if if i do make a mistake i'll just say
well i made a mistake that's not quite
what i meant
um and even though you've got these kind
of retributive
unforgiving armies of activists out
there who will use this against you
just ignore them just do that the
publish and be damned idea you know just
just
i i've made a mistake i've said it i'm
not gonna apologize anymore about this
in fact don't even apologize to them
just say you know well okay that this
was a conversation we had
something was someone misspoke maybe
they did maybe they didn't we're trying
ideas out we're trying to
thrash through these very complex
thoughts um
and if you can't accept that human
beings don't speak like robots
then you're not really a human being at
all i learned
this year for the first time from ben
shapiro the term semantic overload
are you familiar with this well i i can
work out what it means from the
so it was it was yeah and um he
base he's been using it to describe the
words black lives matter
and right that semantically overloaded
it can be multiple things at once
it's this thing when we want it to be
are you against black lives matter well
it's very difficult to say that without
sounding like you hate black people so
it's
it's a it's back to the anti-racism i
did it it's something that can have
more than one meaning and certainly it's
a very clever rhetorical
trope because of course as you say you
cannot disagree with the phrase black
lives matter
no one would this is the weird thing
about it that you know people
making using that hashtag and that
expression because they believe that
unless they do use that expression
we're going to assume they don't believe
that black lives matter it is similar to
i mean this
just goes to show how much things have
escalated so quickly right there was a
thing about five or six years ago
where people started wearing safety pins
as a gesture to show that they weren't
racist it was
it was a very short-lived thing right so
you google it you i'm not i'm not making
it up and no and it got ridiculed by
everyone
including people on the social justice
side because i because of course the
default assumption in a society like
ours is that people aren't racist right
so if you're wearing a safety pin and
saying that anyone who isn't
must be a racer this is absurd right but
we are we are now in
safety pin the world where basically
unless you're saying black lives matter
you assume that black lives do not
matter but that's not true
i still stand by the point that anyone
who
any decent civilized person will
obviously
believe that black lives matter it's
gonna you know you should never assume
that someone doesn't believe that
unless there is incontrovertible
evidence that they don't but that's the
problem it goes back to the critical
race theory idea
that racism is present in every
possible human interaction they don't
ask was this situation racist
they ask how did racism manifest itself
in that situation
and that is the problem so in other
words the entirety of society
is underpinned by racism it's such a
bleak
nihilistic worldview it's it's so
horrible so
yes semantic overload when so i suppose
something that can have multiple
meanings and
and certainly are you two when you talk
about black lives matter are you talking
about the
the uh group are you talking about uh
the concept
well i would suggest now whenever i hear
someone using that phrase i'm always
going to assume you talk about the group
because why would you make the statement
have you all know that have you noticed
now that people are starting to use
black lives matter and blm they've
bifurcated
yes well that's the way that's i think
that started early on as
a way to get around it because we we
need to be able to criticize blm
because as a movement it has all sorts
of ludicrous aspects to it for instance
its belief that we should dismantle
cisgender privilege or
uh attack the western uh nuclear family
or
all of which perfectly push forward the
benefit
and the well-being of black people well
look at their
their intention to defund the police as
well i mean which
which of course would affect uh areas
that are
working class and uh you know and there
is a high proportion of of black and and
ethnic minority people in working-class
areas
it's not going to do them any favor so
this stuff yeah exactly i don't think
dismantling cisgender privilege
is something that's going to go down too
well in certain black communities i i
would i would suggest
okay um well i mean if you know anything
about the history of of of black
gay people they they have had it tough
in this country from
in their in their communities because of
cultural issues religious issues and all
sorts of things
i don't think dismantling system the
privilege is going to go down well so
you're right blm and of course by saying
blm you're avoiding having to say
i oppose black lives matter you can say
i oppose blm
right and and i think lots of people do
i think
the idea of demolishing capitalism right
i think a lot of people are
uncomfortable with i don't understand
why schools
across the country schools like eaton
are putting out statements in support of
black lives matter private schools right
when if you took the black lives matter
agenda and applied it to society
eaton would be raised to the ground it
wouldn't exist
because it charges extortionate rates it
is the
hub and training ground and cradle of
capitalism right
so to have them support a movement that
wants to see them abolished
is utterly [ __ ] right and and i know
i'm not going to use that word i'm using
that word in its literal meaning of to
go backwards
before you start complaining yeah but
you see even i'm doing it now even i'm
worried about
so this is this is the thing that
semantic overload in this
it's even tropey now to say oh it's so
it's so 1984 isn't it you know or
oh well prophesized all of this i'm like
i'm so
bored so so but and i can't imagine what
it's like for you who's further
entrenched
you know really really sort of swimming
through the muck and the the feces and
the blood and the straw
and yeah just desperately trying to get
out the other side so
yeah it's um it's yeah it's
it's what can you say it's depressing do
you not get depressed by this i mean i'm
not suddenly mine this is this is why i
i brought up with with douglas as well i
was like mate i want to know
what you've got to say about how to lead
a good life about what it means to have
human flourishing and fulfillment i want
you to dip into your
bottomless back catalogue of literature
and and
understanding of how you know the
renaissance and the enlightenment and
all this
that's what i want to learn from douglas
murray i don't want him to write
[ __ ] madness of crowds like you know
wonderful book and
the the titanic mcgrath stuff that you
do is fantastic but
as he brings up like when the barbarians
are at the door we'll be debating about
what gender they are whilst we get
kalashnikov in the head
right actually this is it i want to be
able to do other things but i mean i
like so
i love it when i get to write an article
about something that has absolutely
nothing to do with this you know
and and that's that's always good fun uh
and you know obviously because i write
other things i write plays i write
musicals i do all those things and
and i'm still doing that you know i just
finished a new musical but
you just it does dominate unfortunately
the reason it does dominate as you
pointed out and as douglas has pointed
out
unfortunately unless we uh unless we win
this
um nothing else will matter anyway so
actually it is quite important here's
what else i think another reason that i
think
um you guys are so compelled to do it
and james lindsay's a really good
example of this
it's a man with a phd in pure
mathematics yeah
james mate you should be getting this to
mars not doing fake intersectional
studies on
on like uh dog parks but
what i think it is is a little bit like
a more incredulous version of tick-tock
for academics
like imagine what tik-tok must be like
for a 13-year-old you just can't
stop watching it it's so compelling but
there's a layer of indignation as well
because it's
self-contradictory and the hypocrisy is
there and we need to there's
a level of virtue as well as you've said
we need to win this war so on and so
forth
but i really do think that it is the um
low-hanging fruit like woke bashing is
kind of the low hanging fruit
that constantly i can't believe that
they've done this again and then there's
a new one and there's a new one and
there's a new one
and there's a woman in a khaki one piece
with a paypal address up on a whiteboard
telling everyone in the room that
that they're racist and you know sure
and and of course
the risk is always that you're going to
focus on the more extreme
uh manifestations of this phenomenon and
that is that is a risk but
and if it were just that i wouldn't care
honestly if it was just a few nutcases
doing their thing i wouldn't care
it is not that it is not that it is it
is institutional capture
that's what's happened so that does
matter it matters because
these are the people who make our laws
these are the people who will arrest you
for
quote-unquote hate speech these are the
people who will educate your children
these are the people who will get who
will decide whether or not you are
eligible for a degree or not
based on how on your on your field t
to a particular religion basically so
that is a
it is in that sense a civilizational
threat
and in that sense it needs to be it
needs to be counted it isn't
uh the idiots on twitter with the
pronouns in their bios who are just
shouting insults at absolutely everyone
um you can just block them and move on
and you know
they they have limited power um but the
the people who have who have attained
such a sort of such clout
in things like the civil service in
things like the quangos
um you know that's a in the government
even in parliament you know these people
have clout as i say they have power and
they need to it needs to be addressed
because it has an impact on all of us
whether we like it or not so
you know i mean i did i wrote an article
this week actually about this which was
on spiked which
talks about this problem of the culture
war is that there really there are two
versions of the culture war out there
and i call it the tabloid version and
the substantial version for want of a
better term insofar as the tabloid
version is like
snowflakes and and anti-snowflakes and
cucks
and uh you know the libtards
and all the rest of it right so you get
you get all that going on right now i
don't engage in any of that business i
don't call people snowflakes i don't
call people lip tars i'm not interested
in any of that stuff right i don't want
to own the lips because i consider
myself a lib
right um so all of that stuff i don't
get involved in but then there's the
substantial version of the culture war
which is what it really
is and the cultural what it really is is
a a
a a a view of society
where you value liberty or you value
authority
it's liberalism against authoritarianism
and that's that's the culture war
but the problem is that by pushing back
against these
really important issues legitimate
grievances where you're saying
the state shouldn't be overreaching to
police what people say
right you're pushing back on that stuff
and then you get mischaracterized by
people who
play on the ambiguity and say oh you're
one of these snowflake bashing
culture warriors no we are critical of
the culture
of that kind of culture war and want to
hasten its demise
that's not the same thing right we are
critical of those things
what we're actually concerned about is
the
soft authoritarianism of the social
justice ideology which
does require a serious pushback so
people have to be very careful don't let
them do this don't let them say oh
you're just another
pc gone mad brigade type of person
you're just like
notice how i put on a stupid voice when
i
embody yeah you really do but it
shouldn't
but it is a form of stupidity and and
don't let it happen
these are things that we need to address
and we need to do so seriously and
collectively uh and we shouldn't be put
off by people trying to mischaracterize
what we do
uh as being this tabloid version of the
culture war which isn't
really what it is the left has won the
culture war and now they're just driving
around shooting the survivors
that's a question naval ravikant
uh who's an angel investor from america
but the left has won the culture war and
now they're just driving around shooting
the survivors
holy [ __ ] if that's not true well uh
it's difficult and again we get back to
the slipperiness of language insofar as
i do not believe that woke activists are
left-wing in the slightest
uh because they are not remotely
concerned with economic inequality or
class inequality which is at the heart
of what it means to be left-wing
it's a very bourgeois movement the work
movement and so therefore it's it's it's
not really
it's no surprise really that it's the
more elitist universities
where the posher kids tend to go that
have more problems of this
kind because of course if you can't
afford anything you're not going to be
interested
about whether or not you've been
misgendered right are you you're going
to be interested about where you get
your next
plate of food from so that's that's so
it's very difficult but
but we have to say i mean i get into
this all the time am i left-wing
am i right-wing what the hell am i
anymore because people on the left hate
me so much now
and that's because i believe uh the left
has shifted to such degree that it has
become obsessed with identity politics
well the overton window the overton
window of what is
centrist left right all of that has been
i just don't buy into ideology full stop
and that's why
i feel perfectly comfortable in saying
uh this
right-wing say someone like roger
scrutin has some excellent points about
certain things and there are some things
i don't agree with him
on i don't need to be the sort of person
who thinks well he's a right-wing person
so
if i'm on the right i have to agree with
everything he said or or tony ben is a
left-wing person so i must agree with
everything tony bennett says
right because that means you're letting
someone else doing your thinking for you
i think there are
good elements there are impressive
thinkers on the left and the right and
everywhere in between
and and we should be able to to uh
select
and and consider uh which elements are
good and which elements are bad or which
elements we agree with and which we
don't and it
and that does not mean that you suddenly
become uh
left or right wing the problem is of
course that as you know the idea of
being conservative or right-wing has
just become a slur it doesn't really
mean anything i actually don't think
i've stopped even worrying about left or
right everyone thinks i'm
right some people think i'm far right
some people think i'm extreme marxist
left i'm getting that a lot
i get trolled by alt-right people i'm
also called alt-right by the way but the
actual alt-right absolutely hate me and
troll me and they call me a marxist or a
communist
and then like so no one knows what the
[ __ ] i am to the extent i don't even
know what the [ __ ] i am it's fine it
doesn't matter anymore yeah forget it i
mean that was
again that loops back to the challenge i
had when speaking to carl
that i was like i don't know the goal
posts are moving so quickly that i
thought i was playing chess and now i'm
playing rugby
like the whole all the rules of the game
are now out of the window and i've got a
clue what's going on
um did you see the
when durham university went back did you
see that a group of freshers had created
a group
snapchat chat and we're playing a game
of
who could sleep with the poorest fresher
okay that doesn't surprise me but that
so that is
that's proper right versus left stuff
all about classic quality all to do
exactly yeah yeah that
so that and i just i was it went
semi-viral up here in the northeast of
england
um group chat of freshers saying
can we have a you know it used to be
like pull a pig back in
university but apparently if you go to
durham or perhaps like one of the other
red bricks
now it's who can sleep with the poorest
fresher which is like
it goes back to the old bullingdon club
thing of the initiation ceremony
included
burning a 50-pound note in front of a
homeless person that kind of thing yeah
i mean
obviously obviously this uh you know
that's that that is yeah
you could say that's a class-based issue
isn't it that's not the [ __ ]
what's what's your prediction for the
end state
of all of this activism is it inherently
self-contradictory and splinted into
groups that don't agree to the point
where it's going to eat its own tale
it is self-contradictory but it embraces
the contradictions and that's why it's
impossible to reason with it
and that goes right back to the
post-modernist as well and you know
someone like derek
who was very playful uh and
self-contradictory so often deliberately
so and that that means that actually
it's sort of built into their system
it doesn't matter that they have
contradictory thoughts and they can hold
those contradictory thoughts at the same
time
uh it it really doesn't you know it
doesn't matter that they will say
uh that that uh well let's give the
example of the
to go back to the trans example they say
gender is completely a social construct
except for trans people who are born in
the wrong body
it doesn't matter that that can't that
doesn't make any sense because they've
just they they can do that
whereas everyone else relies on the idea
of rationality and rational thought but
the problem is that they would perceive
that to be a sort of
heterosexual patriarchal construct
so you know you're back to square one so
what's going to happen we roll this
forward what's the end state what do you
see look into the crystal ball andrew
and tell us what you said
you know whenever i do this i get it
wrong though i well
there's a lot at stake so i think
well ultimately it's going to go one one
of two ways isn't it other
i i can't envisage that this can just
rumble on as it is
anymore i think there were a lot of
people who were sort of saying before
the explosion this year
of of of the culture war there are a lot
of people who are just saying this will
always be the way
there will always be the sort of extreme
culture warriors pushing their agenda
and most people will just gently push
back and
and we'll constantly be having these
these spats and these disputes
i don't think we can say that anymore i
think one side is going to have to win
out
uh so if the if the culture warriors
went out if the social justice left
or the identitarian left or whatever the
[ __ ] you want to call them win
out we will be living in a under a form
of authoritarianism
right where people are not allowed to
say certain things
will literally be arrested for saying
the wrong thing and
and it will be uh very scary and
dangerous education will be decolonized
to the point where it won't mean
anything anymore
uh artifacts from the past monuments
from the past
a recognition of history will be swept
away um and
we're already seeing that happening but
not as i say not in a crisis point you
know
it's important not to inflate these
things you know i don't agree with mobs
deciding which statues stay up and which
don't right but ultimately that statue
of
edward colston you know i don't think
they should have been able to just
arbitrarily decide and tear it down
but it doesn't amount to a crisis it
doesn't
matter you know we're not talking about
as you said the orwellian principle of
literally revising history
throwing things down the memory hole yet
and that's the qualifier is that the
problem is that these are the seeds of
that and you have to be vigilant against
this stuff
and particularly when it comes to free
speech you have to be incredibly
vigilant it's not something that
that is the default of any given society
it's something that has to be fought for
with each successive generation and
people need to be reminded of the
validity of it and the importance of it
um so i think if for instance a
government were to get in that was
identity obsessed as the current labour
party
is um but they had maybe a more zealous
identitarian leader uh i mean kia
stammer wouldn't be that person
as it happens i know he sort of toys
with it a little bit but he wouldn't be
that sort of extreme zealot
uh identitarian type if you had a
government like that then
you have a very dangerous situation and
you have a society that is going to go
backwards very very quickly
um or the alternative is that we reach
the point where what i'm hoping is in
about
15 20 years time
we will have restored the idea of
liberal values and free speech and
everyone will just go back to just
accepting yes that's
that's the default that's what we should
be having and they'll almost
look back at these years as like what
happened there there was a kind of
hysteria there was a kind of weird
mania that happened and and they'll
probably say but it was it wasn't really
a big deal was it because it just sort
of went away and it was fine
but of course it only it only went away
because people like us are pushing back
against it but
we will be considered the nut cases like
why are we even worried about it it just
wins
yeah i think that's what's gonna i think
i fear that's what's gonna happen
i think i think that that really um
dovetails quite nicely with something
i've been thinking about this year which
is been
reading a lot of existential threats and
existential risk work like toby odds
which is
what prompted my concern to do with the
academics and the low hanging fruit and
the tick tock
and um this year we got a pandemic
it's been anyone who's looked at
existential risk or anything coming out
of the future of humanities institute
knew that this is one of the big ones
the control problem for artificial
general intelligence is another one of
them
but we got delivered touchwood we got
delivered
such a like piss weak
pathogen the mortality rate on it it's
just
not the incubation period and the
transmit ability
are all okay ish the r number could be
you know if i was designing it
one to end the human race the r number
might be a little bit higher and
the incubation period where you're
asymptomatic also might be a little bit
longer
um but we got delivered here's a here's
the beta test here's the demo
exactly i know what you mean what
happens and maybe
this is the ideological conceptual
equivalent where people are trying to
hijack
all of the institutions that mean the
most like um education like chil
children education higher education the
arts
popular culture politics all of that
stuff but they did it
with the marxists that some people
speculate are the conspiratorial pushers
of this that are in the background that
are the trojan horse that this
particular
um ideology is trying to deliver they
chose
they got on the wrong horse they chose
to get into the wrong thing and it was
just so
inherently ridiculous that we are now
inoculated
in the future moving forward maybe i
hope so i think you might there might be
something
to that insofar as i suppose the analogy
is if if we have a much more serious
pandemic we'll be better prepared for it
because we've lived through this and
similarly with the social justice stuff
maybe i don't know a bit but but the but
the problem is that they're pretty well
ingrained
in these institutions now that if this
isn't something it feels like it's just
happened overnight
but it hasn't it's been percolating for
decades yeah so so it's
it is about and again i don't think the
responses
do we do we have a long march through
the institutions the other way do the
liberals
find a way to infiltrate um i i don't
know if that's the right approach
either but it's it's going to take an
awful lot to undo but yes i think
that that could be the case that that
enough people are now pushing back on
this stuff
uh that that when the big wave comes
maybe we'll
i think so we'll be less tolerant of it
yeah
precisely you know because actually this
has only really happened not so much
because of the screaming activists
it's not really them it's not the people
with pink hair screeching and setting
off fire alarms
it's the people capitulating to them
that's the problem you see what should
happen
let's give an example the radar the
royal academy of dramatic art
uh issued a statement saying that they
are systemically racist an institution
as everyone is saying at the moment
uh which begs the question why would
anyone want to go there you know i'm not
i i'm not going to support a racist
institution
i really love the fact that princeton
made that confession and was then
investigated by the department of
education because racism is illegal by
the way
so you know i don't trust it i don't
trust it when i see companies saying
yeah we're working hard to dismantle our
white supremacy i'm like
why are you telling me you're a white
supremacist organization you don't
really
you don't sainsbury's right if
sainsbury's is white supremacist i'm
going to waitrose
i'm just not having this like but you
were educated at oxford andrew so it
would only ever be between waitrose and
marks and spencers right i know i quite
like little what little has good wines
by the way
don't let anyone tell you different fine
so listen i i i would suggest
and not because they don't really mean
it do they there's no way that
sainsbury's think they're a racist
organization of course they don't mean
that
so don't say it you utter idiots don't
say it right
so i can't remember what what my train
of thought on this was
i can't even make it right here's the
example right yeah so radha's statement
that they were and then of course
this this enabled all of these crazy
students and not all of them just a few
to write a hundred page document of
demands
saying what how they need to decolonize
radar 100 pages i'm not kidding right
it's online you can you can feel it it
is the most insane
unhinged document for an awful long time
it is so entitled
it reeks of entitlement it's like we we
get to decide absolutely everything we
believe in these power structures
everything is racist you're
institutionally racist everything you
know it's absolutely insane it's like
the
it's like the ravings of a madman it's
like jack nicholson in the shining
writing all those pages of the same
sentence over and over again because
that's what it is it's the same demand
phrased in different ways a million
[ __ ] times so there's that going on
right and
the response to that should have been
that the heads of radar should have said
thank you for your concerns you're
perfectly free to leave because we're
not going to capitulate to your demands
bye bye
bye go and do your crazy [ __ ] elsewhere
right because we've got to teach people
how to play yago or whatever right so
that's what people should be doing right
but what they don't what they do is they
say oh absolutely they bow down they say
because they don't want
they don't want the scandal they don't
want the twitter storm they don't want
so they capitulate they capitulate so
capitulation is the problem not the
activists themselves
because the activists are always a
minority there's not many of them but
now they know they can get their way
just by so they're like toddlers if you
screech enough they get their way right
you've got to be disciplined with
toddlers
you've got to smack around the head and
say no actually no don't don't see that
okay i could get in trouble for that
i know i'm going to stick by gonna get
andy andy node
final beat up your children beat them up
hit them yeah
i'm sticking with that hit them with uh
anti-racist baby
hit them with auntie a copy of
anti-racist baby that's because it's
hard yeah it's a thick
board book you could do some real damage
to it please
do not obviously we're joking uh final
question
oh why would you get demonetised if you
leave this bit in no not at all
managed to get i have no idea what
youtube youtube loves me at the moment
but i managed to get um
sargon of a clad comment on the media's
view of blackface monetized brilliant
and that was monetized
brilliant it's quite it's quite
inconsistent isn't it i mean even though
we were just joking about hitting a
child with a book
if you wanted to and if you were of a
certain mindset you could take that
literally
because because let's face it the the
social justice that aren't very good at
humor and working out when you're not
being and that wasn't even saturday that
was just being flippant and stupid right
but that but they can t
they can choose to take a stupid comment
literally the problem is that human
interaction is full of stupid comments
that's part of the fun
you know we shouldn't have to worry
about saying something that
that might offend someone you know it's
it's it and and i have to say the
youtubes of the world the facebooks the
googles they're not they're not good at
this you know but
if you've escaped the demonetization
then good for you so far
you have very few have no controversial
elements
you know didn't they even demonetize i
think youtube demonetized diamond and
silk
who were trump supporters but they're
just they're two black women
who are in offense they never swear
they never even swear they don't say
anything they just have political views
that the social tech giants don't like
and they're demonetised it's outrageous
dangerous man final final question who
is going to win the 2020 election
either way we are in trouble uh because
either
either victor will will make the culture
war worse
not better right and the reason for that
is biden has completely bought into
identity politics
a hundred percent and is allowing
himself to be guided in that way and
donald trump also has his version of
identity politics
uh and which is the sort of more sort of
nationalism style
version and he's not let's face it uh
particularly well
uh equipped to deal with this kind of
crisis right he
tends to inflame things rather than make
them better you know fundamentally
uh donald trump likes people who like
him and dislikes people who don't like
him
so and everyone knows this it comes back
to this this essential narcissism
watching those two debate was the one of
the most depressing things i've
ever seen neither of them are equipped
to be president
and um i just i don't think either side
is going to quiet him down because if
trump wins
then the social justice group will take
that as further evidence that they live
in a neo-fascist
society and if if biden wins then i i
suppose
they will be emboldened to to to persist
with these kind of demands
such as the students that radha make and
to to reshape society
according to the principles of their
faith uh so
either way we are [ __ ] have you got a
prediction
do you think can you i know that it's
not your special your special
area but what do you think
i think biden is going to win i think um
i
i i for a long time i thought trump was
i'm sure that trump would have one where
not for coronavirus
i'm i'm pretty sure because the economy
was doing so well uh and because the
it just didn't seem as though
i i think though his handling of the
coronavirus
combined with this kind of general
fatigue
with his uh his behavior and the way
that he tweets he needs to get off
twitter you know if he
much yeah it's um if if the
election was about trump versus if it
was just a personality contest on biden
if that was the competition on biden
biden would lose but sadly
trump continues to make it about himself
which i think is inherently dangerous
because his personality rubs people up
even his own support is the wrong way he
does i mean has no charisma whatsoever
but then
but then trump uh it you know is not
let's put it
delicately it's not states statesmanlike
it's he you know
no one can have looked at the debate
that they had the other week yeah
and say that that was a presidential way
to conduct yourself
i wouldn't be able to vote for either of
them but luckily i'm not in that
position
of having to make a choice you're done
yeah no i
am i don't i think i think you're right
i think at the beginning of 2020 it
would have been
trump to continue um especially given
that
all of the the harbingers of the
apocalypse
that everyone had predicted were going
to occur in 2016.
didn't happen and he did some good stuff
he did some good stuff with the middle
east like that was only this year i
think when when he
you know oh yeah i mean that's that's a
major deal that the the the
the left-wing media are not covering at
all they're staying well well
quite astonishing uh unbelievable but
yeah you know so all of the stuff that
was supposed to happen
didn't happen and the economy was doing
good and
i think it was was it black schooling
that he'd contributed more money to than
any other president ever including the
only black one
it's not about that anymore is it but
this has become the cultural election
and uh i'm afraid that's where we're at
by the way my battery is about to go
and i don't have that case we're gonna
we we're gonna we're gonna leave it
there
titania mcgrath's little book of
intersectional activism linked in the
show notes below
including some of her favorite
characters from history and how you can
uh
teach your children to is that that
versus
anti-racist baby and that's you perfect
i think it's time to tiny mcgrath's book
give that to your kids
that's the way to go it's it's funny
because a friend of mine i sent it to a
friend of mine and
it looks like a kid's book and her
husband thought it was for their
four-year-old daughter
and gave it to him she was delighted and
then of course she had to explain
actually it's not for you
sorry which is heartbreaking take that
back a little susie look andrew
thank you so much to tony mcgrath's
twitter your twitter everything else
will be linked in the show notes below
enjoy the remainder of the amalfi coast
mate
thank you very much for having me
[Music]